hi guys dr. Berg here in this video I'm going
to give you some tips on combining the body types
with keto and intermittent fasting if you have all
three these together you can really get your body
healthy fast now the book that's coming out very
soon and I've been saying that for the last year
and a half but it's really at the last little
phase right now has all this information in
detail so I'm going to give you a couple tips on
it right now but we're putting this layer of body
types over the ketogenic diet and intermittent
fasting just to make it an amazing program so
let's talk about the adrenal body type first and
yes you might be a combination of two of these
or three of these or four of these but I'm not
going to get into that in this video we're just
going to talk about what you would do if you're in
adrenal type okay so you're going to do ketogenic
and you're also going to do intermittent fasting
but you're going to go a little higher with the
protein 2 instead of 3 ounces of protein you lose
6 ounces of protein for the adrenal because you're
in a breakdown mode of protein eating a little
bit more you also need a little bit more sleep
stress reduction you want to do things to bring
the stress down you want to go long walks you
want to give yourself more recovery time you
want to probably even take naps but try to get
a little bit more sleep on that I would like
to use the acupressure tool to my body to get
me to wind down faster you can do that as well
potassium is important for the adrenal so that
means a lot of greens the electrolyte powder
would be good but potassium helps the adrenal
calm down the physiological relaxer mineral for
the flight-or-fight nervous system you actually
need more cholesterol with the adrenal body type
because all the hormones that are produced by the
adrenal are made from cholesterol so you don't
want to go low fat at all egg yolks are the best
ok vitamin C foods that's the vegetables so when
you get the potassium from your vegetables you
also get the vitamin C vitamin C is very very
important for making adrenal hormones and just
supporting the adrenal gland itself because
it stores vitamin C to make its hormones ok
ovary type you gotta go organic completely one
hundred percent organic you cannot be exposed to the
GMO foods because when you're an ovary type
you have a problem with estrogen and if you
have problem estrogen you might be more at risk
for cancers breast cancer uterine cancer and so
those tissues are very sensitive to estrogen and
things called endocrine disruptors which are any
chemicals that mimic estrogen glyphosate which
is an herbicide mimics estrogen so we want to
go non-gmo and that would be because they don't
label it you have to just go with organic so do
organic foods vegetables and your meats and dairy
as well you want to go a little bit higher with
your protein six ounces of protein are generally
the recommendation but really depends on on how
much you need personally it could be a little less
but generally it's a little bit more test it out
cruciferous vegetables are very important having
an ovary problem simply because they are anti
estrogen 'ok okay so that's why you would want
to include them Brussels sprouts are good kale
is good kale shakes those types of things iodine
is good too in the form of sea kale because it's
it lowers estrogen naturally higher amounts of
cholesterol because the hormones that are made
from the ovary are steroids and they need higher
cholesterol to make those as a precursor thyroid
okay you need a little lower protein for the
thyroid because the metabolism is so slow iodine
is going to be important so sea kelp is going to
be essential because that's the mineral that helps
make the thyroid hormones if you ever see t3 or
t4 that's the number of iodine molecules that are
connected to that hormone and then also if you can
see calc you also have selenium which is another
mineral to help the conversion if you have a real
bad thyroid your metabolism is really slow you're
going to have to do intermittent fasting down to
eventually one meal a day that's what's going to
take on some cases to get them to lose weight but
make sure that you don't go low-calorie never make
sure that with the thyroid because you're going
to slow the metabolism down even more so the only
problem that you would run into is to make get
enough calories or enough nutrients from you know
it has to be quite robust but you probably don't
want to do a lot of cruciferous with diuretic the
truth are because that can deplete iodine so do
other vegetables like spinach and leafy greens
and the peppers and things like that now the liver
if it's a liver body type go a little low on the
protein like three ounces of protein but if you're
a big guy maybe you need six ounces okay but try
not to go too much because too much protein
destroys the liver limit the amount of nuts
that you consume it's easy to start going crazy
with peanut butter and nuts but that can aggravate
the liver as well cruciferous vegetables are a
must because those vegetables help repair liver
function go gradual with your fat when you're
doing intermittent fasting sometimes you can overdo
it and jam up the liver and the gallbladder just
kind of go graduate that make sure it's not too
much you need some but not not a crazy amount
not as much as an adrenal case lots of greens
they'll quite huge salads very very important
now it let's say you do one of these programs
and it doesn't feel right it's not producing the
results or the effect then you probably the wrong
body type so sometimes I'll have a person try
this and then try this and you might find that
they do really good on this then they're probably
an adrenal types or the sometimes it's a crossover
and you don't know what your primary body type is
all right so the books coming up soon but in the
meantime you can use this as a guideline thanks
so much for watching hey you probably already
subscribed but if you haven't press this little
button down below and I will keep you updated